desk biologists themselves and be like
so what's your definition of life I
might just be like ah
well they might have some definition and
then the next person would have a
different one or more often they would
just want to like answer the question be
like oh I you know I just study pythons
like that's what really fascinated me
and and and maybe that's what made me
sort of quip about you know astronomers
having it more easy like all these
people study the same thing they all
study life and uh either don't know how
to define it or they come up with
definitions that are pretty different
from each other and that I found that
that has really stuck with me and
eventually I just sort of felt like I
need to dive deep into this any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
welcome everybody to a very promising
and Lively episode of the into the
impossible podcast I started this
podcast uh in Earnest in 2020 during the
pandemic when I said I was your fearful
host but I've become a lot less fearful
and a lot more Fearless since uh the
Advent of things like uh the maybe
perhaps the end of the covid-19 pandemic
we'll talk with today's guest who's
renowned uh Communicator writer thinker
journalist uh it's Carl Zimmer joining
us all the way from the Nutmeg State on
the East Coast I think I got that right
how are you today Carl I'm good I'm good
it's great to meet you and today we're
talking about your latest book your most
recent book a life's Edge which kept me
on the edge of my seat for a variety of
reasons and it's somewhat remarkable to
me that perhaps of all the authors who
have graced you know me with their
presence on this podcast this book has
perhaps the highest number of
intersectional networking nodes with
people both located here in San Diego or
former guests of the podcast or folks
that we did not get on the podcast
because they passed away and other uh
other sort of assorted connections that
really makes this conversation unique
but I always like to have my author
guests go through an exercise which
you're not supposed to do but we don't
have anything else to go on if we have
not encountered your work and that's to
judge your book by its cover
Carl I want to ask you what is the
Genesis the origin story of the title of
the book the illustration and I always
find the subtitle fascinating and as I
said you can't say my publisher forced
me to do
oh it's this is all mine I'm happy to
say I mean sometimes my editors Stephen
Morrow Dutton is very good with titles
and so on so if I'm just if it's not
working out for me I know he'll he'll
have my back but um this time around
yeah life's Edge
uh you know I
I think what I wanted to convey with
that was that
um we have this idea of life being a
thing and there's sort of a a border
between life and whatever isn't life
whether it's life and death or living
things and inanimate things
and I wanted to in a way I'm sorry
playing with that that you know this
there's this Edge like it's sharp
um and you know I wanted to sort of make
the point that it's actually not and
it's very hard to find and you can get
kind of lost looking for it and that
sort of leads to the subtitle which is
this search this search for what it
means to be alive because you know that
that really has been
um a struggle for for centuries
um and and it's one that um
you know I think biologists themselves
sometimes don't even really acknowledge
just how much of a struggle it has been
and how much longer there is to go
and um you know we were trying to figure
out like what would be a good thing to
put on the cover and I there are lots of
Critters that I talk about in the book
lots of cool things and
um and and weird things and we settled
on
um a picture I'm just going to hold it
up here to show you this is this is a
this strange rainbow colored blob this
is a brain organoid
um it is was started from a volunteer
Who provided skin cells and then
biologists actually the University of
California San Diego
um coaxed that skin cell with some
chemicals
through a series of steps and
developments to become a neuron a brain
cell and not just any brain cell but the
kind of
early brain cell that would form in an
embryo
which then multiplied and grew into
something like a brain and so one of the
names that people give this thing is a
brain organoid
and it sits there in a bath of chemicals
it the the neurons release electrical
signals
um and you know there are these deep
questions that something like that
creates I mean these things have only
been around for a few years but
um you know they can grow to leave the
size of a
um you know a sugar cube a sand grain
maybe even a little bigger getting
towards rice grain size
are they alive are they living things
you know we you know when we think about
ourselves as being alive
we really think about it in terms of our
brain you know like well uh of course
I'm alive because I'm conscious
um and you know we we actually like
have come to Define death by brain death
so here you have this thing that's made
of human brain cells that behaves very
much like a human brain it's not
connected to a human body
uh but the cells metabolize and they can
divide so what is it is it alive
um I think that would be a very hard
thing a question to answer and and I
look at other these hard cases in the
book
yeah the book is really sort of the
exploration of of the edge of the
boundary between living and non-living
and I always find those things get us
into trouble you know and things are
kind of ambiguous the human mind as you
point out in the book you know is is not
so simple uh to really model or predict
even and now with the Advent of you know
large language models and and chat gbt
type things and past guests on the show
Max tegmark has made the argument that
life 3.0 is is really basically here and
will be abundant and perhaps
um
supersede Life 2.0 I think we're I think
we're like 2.1 in his in his cognition
uh scheme but but yes the brain organoid
was a fascinating uh episode with uh
with my colleague Allison motra we did a
conversation we
um I've solicited a question for you uh
from him which we will uh talk about uh
he Raves about his experience getting to
know you and there are many many
connections here at San Diego that we'll
get into including the Miller Yuri
experiment Harold Erie and Miller we're
eventually here uh at UC San Diego Romeo
marrow who's a renowned professor in
chemistry theoretical chemist who's here
who's did a lot of contributions to some
of your piece in the New York Times from
a year or two ago when the pandemic was
was sort of fresh and and it was vital
to get that information out but I want
to start with maybe a surprising
connection which maybe you didn't know
about or maybe you wouldn't have agreed
actually you agreed to come on the
podcast after a very cheeky and perhaps
annoying tweet of mine where you said
imagine if astronomers couldn't agree
agree on what a planet was you know and
here we are we can't agree on what life
is I said Carl I have news for you I
have good news and bad news so we we
don't agree and it's not so simplified
or simple to really ascertain what is a
planet what is a star even
um what is the universe uh what is the
Multiverse these are all sort of
ambiguous things which relates really to
the first topic that that I encountered
in the book that had a Nexus with this
podcast and surprisingly Carl that's
with uh Ben Shapiro who is a friend of
mine and has been on the podcast three
times and you talk about life uh his
quote is one of the opening uh chapters
of the book you talk about life begins
at conception
the conservative pundit Ben Shapiro
declared in 2017. that's not a religious
belief that's science and I want to ask
about that because
um I think these Essences essence of
some of the the polarization that we
suffer in science and Society is because
of the difficulty the human mind has
with ambiguous States so Schrodinger
type States and Schrodinger will play a
big role in this podcast as you
undoubtedly are aware so um when you
have a superposition of possibilities
live and unlived fetus a baby
um uh you know machine gun and anti-tank
weapon uh you know you straddle the the
spectrum of of reasonableness ranging
from life begins at conception as one
person began might believe to life can
be terminated up until the point of you
know full full-term birth
so what what do you think is that sort
of Border I mean is it something that
we're fundamentally doomed to never
really be able to resolve because of the
ambiguity in these in these matters in
other words because the human brain is
so bad at dealing between things that
aren't you know exactly black and white
is that part of the difficulty or is it
deeper than that in the definition of
what life is
just a quick pause to ask you for a
small favor while my thumb is occupied
with old Albert on it yours is
presumably freed up to leave a thumbs up
on this video really helps me a lot with
a good old-fashioned YouTube algorithm
thanks a lot now back to the video
well I think in the case that you
provided
um I think the I think the problem I
think one of the fundamental problems
with these sorts of slogans like life
begins at conception is like
I've looked like it's very difficult to
to actually like figure out what people
mean when they say that
um
there are as I explained in the book
hundreds of definitions of life but I
never actually hear somebody
um actually like really it's hard to
find anyone lay it out what they really
mean when they say that life begins at
conception
um because and and you know if you know
there are plenty of ways in which you
can think about life
um
that
um that would not begin to be me in the
beginning of conception because the
cells that gave rise to that zygote were
themselves alive
um now you may one may want to say well
there's something special about that
life but now all of a sudden we're in a
different ball game I mean
um that's different than saying Life
Begins it's saying well this special
Life Begins or when I say life I mean
this you know so I don't think you know
it's so so saying Life Begins the
conception is is a it's a it's a catchy
slogan but if you really try to uh
analyze it it falls apart and um you
know uh as as a society
um you know as as a democracy uh we need
to uh come to agreements
about these things in agreements with
people we may disagree with
um there is you know I think it's it's
telling that
um you know
we have ended up with
you know I'd say a fair agreement about
you know talking about life and when it
ends
um you know you know the idea of brain
death is is a it's you know in the
history of understanding life it's
pretty recent
um it really only started to emerge in
the 1960s
um and it and you know and it emerged
because uh
of Technology it wasn't because of some
philosophical issue or its own it was
basically that there were ventilators
that could keep people
um their heart still beating when
otherwise they would have been dead and
transplant surgeons were figuring out
how to save people's lives by giving
them transplants and they sort of felt
like you know we need to like
you know for the for for the good for
for the good of everybody here we need
to figure out
what we mean to say that someone is
still alive or someone is dead and that
definition
you know that was hashed out very
clearly explicitly uh with philosophers
and bioethics and so on and
um you know that definition is brain
death now that is can be controversial
sometimes and there have I write in the
book about you know you know there have
been cases where people like no I don't
I don't want to accept this and I don't
want to accept what the state of
California says is dead
right um but it's but it's it's nothing
compared to the um conflict over uh over
over the beginning of uh of you know
when we talk about uh embryos and
fetuses
yeah and that that kind of you know is a
is a hybrid of a hybrid or a
superposition because you're dealing of
life and then an abortion you're dealing
with the you know the potential
termination of a life
um or potential life the potential
termination of a potential life
um but in you know in in terms of you
know but but I mean just uh just uh to
to point out how complicated this all is
yeah
um what do we mean by a potential life
you just use that phrase as if we all a
know what it means and we all agree on
what that means
um and I would just say like we all need
to like stop and really think
more carefully about these things
because it's it is a lot slippier slip
more slippery than we may appreciate and
it's getting more slippery and so this
actually brings us back to those brain
organoids
um
you know because uh you know just as
technology has you know uh uh you know
created a new
um challenge in terms of understanding
when life ends you know in terms of you
know brain death ventilators
transplantation and so on technology has
made it possible to start creating
organoids uh and
um
so you know every you know these are
just like from skin cells yeah as I said
so every one of your skin cells
has this potential life maybe not a life
of a you know someone walking around and
you know being on a podcast sure but you
know if we Define life in other ways by
saying well you know act you know brain
activity brain brain would appear to be
brainwave oscillations
um you know development of different of
different layers of the cortex it's all
there
so if our every skin cell in our body
has potential life like what is Our
obligation to our skin because we are
sloughing off countless skin cells every
single day
you know all those potentials lies every
day and I'm not trying to be facile here
I'm just sort of saying no you know
let's really think about let's think and
rethink about all these terms that we're
using because they're not as simple as
we we tend to think they are
yeah I mean I've had on several imminent
uh Scholars philosophers of
Consciousness in the brain and and
activity you know related to that domain
which you just mentioned is sort of the
cinequa non of of lively maybe human
life or termination of the right to
terminate although you pointed on the
book case of a young girl who basically
goes through puberty and and menstruates
and so forth and she's brain to so
um but but again getting back to what I
think is the not the explanation the
resolution of the difficulty but I think
the the origin the problem when we talk
about well pornography is something that
you know when you see it okay that that
affects people but it's very different
from you know autonomy over one's own
body or a living a baby I mean nobody
ever you know comes up to a woman who's
caring determines this has the fetus you
know or how's your embryo doing they
usually say how's your baby when's the
baby due
um so again it's something you know when
you see it but with pornography it
doesn't impact again your autonomy your
freedom them possibly being made
criminal in certain locations so I guess
the stakes are so much higher and even
with gun rights I mean you don't need uh
you're you know you don't have to own a
gun right there's no there's no mandate
and I I think even reasonable people
members of the NRA would say look you
can't operate a portable thermonuclear
device and call that you know part of
the well-regulated militia on the other
hand you know having some mode of
self-defense might be applicable to even
uh David Hogg you know or some some
activist on the opposite side so I guess
I'm saying is the stakes are so high
combined you know with this particular
topic and I think that combined with the
human beings inability to deal with
these questions because we are classical
creatures we live in a Quantum world and
I think it's appropriate you know we
should turn to Schrodinger who did
approach this topic way back when in the
in the in the 50s when he was an eminent
you know Nobel Laureate
coming up with the canonical equations
of quantum mechanics that govern the
behavior of essentially all of chemistry
and and part of physics and obviously
chemistry is very deeply related to life
and its existence and its definition now
Schrodinger like these people that I
talk to like David Chalmers like Nick
balstrom and other people when I asked
them what is consciousness I get a
20-minute definition Carl and and that's
okay because look if I we can't Define
what it means to be a bat that doesn't
affect some woman's right to do
something with her body or with a fetus
or with a baby right but in this case it
does so I think Schrodinger's question
is is basically you know has not been
definitively answered but I think your
book is an approach to surveying the
landscape both from the macroscopic down
to the quantum and I wonder you know
you've done a lot of work she has her
mother's laugh is is genetic uh and and
nature the history of heritability uh
planet of viruses you've done a lot in
this field what is it about this
question that seems to Fascinate you so
much so that you've dedicated a
considerable amount of your professional
career to issues of the biological
sciences life chromosomes and viruses
Etc
um so I started out as a journalist
um at a magazine called discover and and
you know I was
just you know with an assistant editor
there doing some copy editing and some
fact checking and then they let me start
to write little articles and you know I
would
you know write about all sorts of
different things because you know we
couldn't be you know too precious about
what we would or wouldn't write about
um so I was writing about physics and
you know technology and astronomy uh and
all sorts of stuff and I was enjoying
all of it
um but
um I it just felt like the when I would
write about biology
I just they would just be like I would
just be reading a study and I'd say like
wait what like really like this exists
or this is how this works like I would I
would just continually be surprised like
you know every week there would be at
least one thing that just just blew my
mind and so and and so once I was at the
point where I could kind of gravitate
towards
um when I wanted to write about features
that discover and then working uh with
other magazines like natural geographic
or the Atlantic
um you know biology was really what I
wanted to to write about and it just you
could also just write about so much and
yet it was all interconnected in
interesting ways uh most importantly
through Evolution
um that you know this principle uh just
helps you to understand how everything
there are these themes to how thing
living things work and not only that but
it all comes from the same common
ancestors
um so uh and uh you know and I've had
the luxury of you know well I'm you know
I'd start in the 90s and so I I didn't
realize it but I was going to be riding
this wave
of
um you know the modern science of
genomics of of molecular biology which
just you know just like took us down to
this incredible level of detail that I
really couldn't imagine before you know
I'm
you know I'm writing stories now that
are regularly about you know like people
who are analyzing you know the genomes
of hundreds of different species in one
study and that's just standard like
there's so much information and and the
insights are really profound but you
know along the way you know I I have to
say that every now and then I'd be like
okay like clearly like what really you
know I'm interested in is life
okay what exactly am I writing about you
know and you know I mean I had read
Schrodinger and you know and other
things but but you know then I would
start to think like
well you know have people really sorted
this out very well you know
um and I you know I would ask biologists
themselves and be like so what's your
definition of life and you know I'd be
talking to someone who studies pythons
or somebody who studies crabs or
somebody who studies Venus fly traps and
they'd just be like ah
uh well they might have some definition
and then the next person would have a
different one or more often they would
just really not want to like answer the
question be like oh I you know I just
study pythons like I you know like and
so that's what really fascinated me and
and and maybe that's what made me sort
of quip about you know astronomers
having it more easy like all these
people study the same thing they all
study life and uh you either don't know
how to define it or they
I come up with definitions that are
pretty different from each other and
that I found that that has really stuck
with me and eventually I just sort of
felt like I need to dive deep into this
and it was so interesting to see how
just how long of a history uh there's
been to this and how the struggles that
people have today in the 21st century
are very they Echo things in the 1800s
the 1700s the 1600s this is a long
struggle and we're not done with it yeah
and I wonder how much of that is driven
by you know something I call the
academic media hype complex which is
that you know that we researchers need
to depend on funding sources which
depend on our ability to get results and
drive uh research Publications or obtain
funding obtain students to work with us
and collaborate with other researchers
and I wonder if you're journalistic you
know kind of uh neck hairs ever really
stand up on edge when you're when you're
dealing with people I'll I'll just say
my friend Lee Cronin features very
prominently in the book and especially
at the very end I don't think it's a
spoiler of a you know for a little while
and you know it's not like I'm uh
revealing you know who done it but you
know his assembly Theory and he was
asked famously and my audience would be
quite annoyed at me if I didn't at least
you know press you on your opinions
about it but uh they've pressed me and
you know why why you know why is it that
he said in in 2010 at his Ted Talk that
you know life would be created in the
lab in the next 22 months or whatever he
said and here we are you know 13 years
later and we can't seem to to come up
with it I wonder what do you believe is
is you know the job of a journalist
communicating to the to the public or
Popular Science author uh both of which
careers you've you've uh and you've
enjoyed
um what role do you have to sort of you
know call out like this doesn't really I
mean you guys have been saying similar
things as you said for decades now and
and this this is true in the alien you
know extraterrestrial intelligence
hunting field that I'm tangentially
involved with at times
um so at what point do you ever inject
yourself into the story you do a lot of
you know this is like a memoir of this
book in a part you know you're doing
experiments you're creating you know
compounds you're meeting with a faculty
here in California and elsewhere what
what is your responsibility as a
journalist or on a mission and a popular
science book to maybe Expose and call
out BS when you see it do you ever have
that as a conflict
how does it as a conflict I see it as
you know one of the jobs that science
writers and journalists more generally
should do
um and you know I I I I think that you
know
when writing about science you know
uh the challenge is that
um there's a lot of work to be done to
to explain the
um
the ideas and the experiments
uh the the the the research on the
concepts uh in these areas like that
that takes a lot of work and a lot of
space
um and so but you know at the same time
you know I I think it's also I think it
is important you know if people are are
trying to
um you know hype up
um the stuff that they're doing to
um you know to to take a skeptical look
especially you know if people are sort
of setting their own goals I mean I've
done that a lot um I would say
um I'd say I've done that
um I'm trying to think areas where I've
done that you know the um well with the
with the genome you know the the human
genome you know they're the um
when Francis Collins and others were
were uh James Watson were lobbying
um
for the money to do the first draft of
the human genome
it was a big ask you know they were
wanting billions of dollars and they
were
um trying to justify it and
um you know they and so
they they were you know promising that
there would be a lot of medical benefits
that would come out of it and you know
like it it you know fi I would say like
you know five years after the drafts you
know genome was published in I guess was
that 2001 2002 you know it's not like
you know people were getting cured of
cancer or something like that and you
know like there were years were going by
where you know critics were saying like
like what you know what
way you know did did you you know what
what about those promises that you made
and um you know and you know I think
it's important to quote those promises
and look at what's happened but I but I
also think that you know it's even when
you
you know you know remember the history
of these things it's also important to
to recognize the complexity because like
if I had if I would go say to like a
cancer biologist and say you know what
you know like they made a bunch of
promises and you know in in five years
you know there weren't any great Cancer
drugs that came out of it so I tell you
what you can't use the human genome
anymore
they say whoa whoa whoa no no no I'm
sorry I'm not giving this back this this
map of the human genome is a tool that I
cannot live without and the fact is that
there are a lot of uh of really
promising uh treatments
today you know we're talking like two
decades later
um that where you know the human you
know having that map of the human genome
was just essential it just was so you
know uh
if you were expecting things in five
years and you started getting them in 20
you know what is that it I mean I don't
think that I I think I think it's it
would be wrong to say like ah it was a
complete waste it wasn't it just you
know there is a contrast between
people's expectations when the project
started and how things really played out
right on the hype side you know you
feature a lot of very interesting
anecdotes that I've drawn upon many
times in my career both to illustrate
the kind of Nexus between you know
promotion and publication and scientific
research and funding and one of those uh
is very famous because it appears in the
movie contact uh featuring past guest uh
Avatar Jill Tarter played by Jody Foster
and uh and it was written Corin by Carl
Sagan and his wife and jurian who's been
a guest on this podcast as long along
with her daughter I think I've I'm the
first uh podcaster to have both of them
on on the podcast and when we discussed
that particular movie there's a scene in
there where Bill Clinton is on the White
House lawn he's talking about how
revolutionary this discovery of the
signal
from Alien extraterrestrial intelligence
is now of course that wasn't real but
the actual footage is real and he's
really talking about the discovery of
these microbes found on a meteorite that
landed in Antarctica where I've been
twice and
that Discovery and you go through it so
here's a meteorite and by the way uh if
you have a DOT edu email address you
sign up for my mailing list and I will
send you a meteorite uh that's Brian
keating.com list because I love uh
Distributing materials but it was kind
of bespeaks of not the origin of life
itself but the origin of Life perhaps on
Earth or some form of Life coming from
Mars and I like to point out that that
it took a very long time and was really
if you if you survey even scientists and
you say what's the status of the proof
or dispositiveness of the Allen Hills
meteorite in terms of life on on you
know for Martian microbes and even
scientists will tell me uh that oh it
could be still you know hasn't been
definitively ruled out it was published
in science as you point out uh it was
leaked and then Clinton talked about it
Dan golden used it as as a motivation to
get more funding for NASA's nascent
astrobiology the point is a lot of
people in the public never know the
inside baseball unless they read this
book book or have seen you know in in in
another format so what obligation do you
think a scientist has you know to
maintain a budget for publicization of
retractions and and sort of to to come
clean about this I'm thinking also of
the discovery of arsenic life also
published in science also uh shown not
to be replicable uh these are huge
things and it impacts the Public's
understanding so do you think scientists
I've called for scientists to maintain
some PR budget for retractions as sort
of a lock box what do you think how do
you think we can handle this so that the
public is not left left with a sense of
mistrust of what scientists actually do
um well
uh you know the the Arsenic life example
is is a is a really interesting one I
mean that that was a case where
um people had found bacteria in a lake
in California that seem to be using
arsenic to build their DNA uh which
would really just be just something that
we have never seen before
um and
um the I remember that that hype was
that was really kind of mind-blowing
um from from the journal and from NASA
you know and they just they were just
ready to ready to launch with it and um
but I you know there were
you know I I uh at the time I was
writing a fair amount for slate and my
editor and I um Dan engberg who's a
great science writer in his own right
he's at the Atlantic now we were saying
like just emailing back and forth like
hey I don't know this this seems kind of
funny to us and and I had there's like
you know this is back in the age of
blogging and it was a very small blog
that I uh a couple small blogs that I
like to read that I I mean small just in
terms of they had small audiences
um Big Ideas small audiences but you
know I was one of them and then they
were like
microbiologists and such and they were
like this doesn't seem right so I just
said look let me just go like
check with a bunch of experts
um and so I I think I just you know just
emailed like a dozen you know top people
and
pretty much they are all like this is
terrible
like okay that's the story so that's
what I wrote like you know I think the
headline was like this paper should have
never been published I think that was in
quotes like that was what one of these
people said
you know and and um it really you know
and and um I think that that accurately
reflected this sort of feeling of a lot
of scientists and you know they
actually then published
um you know their own studies saying
like look no this was all an artifact
you know you you didn't control for
things carefully and so on and so forth
that is a part of science like the the
the sort of getting ahead of your skis
and um you know it's it's not a judgment
it's just an observation and I start the
book with someone who got way ahead of
his ski skis about a hundred years ago
James Butler Burke this physicist who
thought that he had created life in the
lab and people believed him he was being
celebrated
um around the world like newspapers are
calling him you know his he published a
book shortly afterwards about this
incredible experimented with radium and
protein broth and
people are saying this is like on par
with the Origin of Species you know
um this is artificial life they would
use these terms and it was all wrong it
was complete completely botched and you
know a few scientists you know um
doggedly proved that that was the case
but
you know the chat I I agree that you
know it's important to to put some focus
on you know the law you know what
happens after the big flashy paper do
the findings hold up do they not
uh where does science go because science
is not just one flashy paper at a time
but you know the fact is that
um
it's a lot harder to
um capture people's interests about
you know a retraction of a paper they
may barely have remembered reading about
if they read about it at all five or ten
years ago so
um it's not easy and it's not just doing
it doesn't necessarily uh fix that
problem you're identifying
I wonder if it's a journalism problem as
much as uh you know as as a uh as a
scientific problem in that as you say
you know we've had my own encounter with
you know front page above the fold in
the New York Times discovery which you
know then later had to be rescinded the
claims that we made not that we didn't
make a blunder we didn't uh you know
leave the lens cap on the telescope but
we misinterpreted the signal as coming
from the inflationary origin of the
entire beginning of time and in fact we
had seen just specks of dust in the
cosmic Interstellar wind uh and when
that was finally retracted to to the
extent that it was thanks to a
re-analysis of our data that was on you
know page eight you know 16 of the
Saturday edition that it's the least
read Edition so I wonder yeah if we can
uh if we can sort of have both in terms
of Ethics um and in terms of
publicization there are many kind of
ethical edges as well as life edges uh
we we have uh for example I I did an
interview with James tour who's uh he's
actually a um uh how should I say he's a
he's a Messianic Jew which means that he
uh was actually born Jewish became
Christian and he's extremely devout but
highly cited name distinguished chair at
Rice University and you know he he
presented a survey uh that was done
independently I think it was done by the
National Science Foundation and it said
like what is the ask the public what is
the most advanced form of life that
scientists have been able to create and
uh the but the the majority of
respondents said something like a frog
there was admittedly only a few
different choices there was you know a
cell DNA and of course you know it's you
know there's nothing even really close
to that but I wonder and it reminded me
of a talk of a another study by the
National Science Foundation asked
Americans how uh which which happened
does the sun orbit the Earth or not and
25 of Americans said the sun does orbit
the earth and so you know now people
aren't publishing papers anymore that
say you know the sun orbits the earth
the way they might have done in you know
ptolemy's day and the Ptolemy times or
the Alexandria times but uh but people
like La Jolla Dennis and Craig ventner
who's I don't believe he makes an
appearance in this book maybe uh didn't
but you know he'll come out and say well
he created artificial life you know the
first artificial life
um but and and even closer to home is
the case of the Miller Yuri experiment
because if you ask people the even
scientifically well inclined people
people I've had on the podcast they'll
say that the Miller Yuri experiment you
know definitively showed that we could
create if not DNA you know precursors to
DNA and as you point it's really not
true right so
um how do we what do we uh you know how
do we combat that because I think the
light of Truth you know it should be
most prominent and we should be come
clean about what we are able to do such
that when we do make life in the lab or
do discover extra that people will be
appropriately
um uh appreciative of it so I I don't
know if I'm if there's really a question
there but I'd love to hear your your
take on it like what do we what do we
make of the of the of the very very
large incentivization to make these bold
claims and the lingering aftertaste in
the public that may redown to the
detriment of the public
no I I do I do think that a you know a
big challenge uh with all this is just
our you know that it's
there's just a lot of science that gets
done and it's hard to you know you we we
come up with these sort of short hands
to remember what's going on
um and you know I I mean uh you know if
you talk to
um you know certainly in my experience
like talking to scientists like if we if
we move out of their field of expertise
um you know they're kind of you know
castanig a little fuzzy on things as
well and I don't begrudge them I mean
it's just it's it's challenging and and
I think that we just you know I think
the way that the the human mind works is
to go from like okay here are the you
know here's this interesting but
complicated set of results to being like
okay here's this quick quick simple
story
then I'll remember that instead you know
you know I don't I don't think we're
going to you know solve the problem of
the human brain
um uh anytime soon
um but you know I I think that um you
know if you wanna if you're bringing up
like fundamental things about you know
the Sun and so on like
um you know I don't I don't see a place
for like journalists to be like you know
the way that news works just makes it
difficult to address those sort of
fundamental issues I mean there's
another
there's another number I think it's
maybe the same survey that you looked at
my one that really caught my eyes that
actually the majority of people
think that electrons are bigger than
atoms I mean that's like a majority
um and you know and I'm like that's
interesting because I have no idea why
people would think that
um but most people do and most Americans
who are surveyed at least and um
you know we're not gonna I mean like the
format of news is not such that we will
like have a headline saying like news
flash electrons are smaller than atoms
like that's just not that's not going to
work
um you know the best that I can think of
is you know just a redoubling uh a
an emphasis on you know better Science
Education uh from kindergarten through
high school like I just I keep coming
back to that I just I mean you know most
people are not most people are not
science phds most people don't even take
sign you know take a college science
class
um this is where our Focus needs to be
yeah just a quick closing anecdote about
that survey about the sun orbiting the
Earth so I I cited that statistic on the
occasion of Galileo's uh 450th birthday
I believe it was and at his actual final
resting place prison in our chetri Italy
outside of Florence and there was a you
know crowd of astronomers gathered there
and I said at first I showed the
statistic because it was you know it was
kind of pertinent it said 25 of
Americans believe that the sun orbits
the earth and all the Italians oh stupid
American uh
and I said but guess what and I changed
and I showed them the European research
council did the same survey and 33
percent of Europeans believe that so
they're really not in a position to to
judge us Americans
um one of the best uh the most enjoyable
Parts as a physicist was the kind of uh
delineation and and the history of how
physics has really informed biology and
wonder if you could comment on that what
were some of the surprising things you
learned about I I didn't really realize
you know Della Brook I obviously I knew
Schrodinger but Della Brook obviously uh
Lisa meitner was an x-ray
crystallographer I believe
um uh Watson was also trained as a
physicist
Crick was changed as a physicist perhaps
there are many many crossovers between
physics which is reputed to be the
science of the 20th century and biology
which is reputed to be the science of
the 21st century so what were some of
the surprising findings and learnings
that you encountered along the way of
writing this book
um I I think it was
very interesting to kind of get into the
perspective of people like Del Brook and
Schrodinger and these other physicists
who were
um
and you know and and correct I mean
looking at you and just thinking of from
their perspective as people looking at
life and you know from the from their
experience you know studying
radioactivity studying quantum physics
and so on and saying like huh okay like
quantum physics I think I get quantum
physics but life okay that's weird and
and I want to like think about life
um as you know so and they were you know
it's very different than the the sort of
the main
sort of trunk of the main channel of the
history of biology where you you had
um naturalists you know you had you know
starting with Aristotle you know just
splashing around lagoons and and you
know dissecting uh uh aquatic uh
creatures and so on you know all the way
on through you know Linnaeus you know
marching around in Lapland and capturing
every living thing he could find
um
so so that um
you know obviously biology has taken in
all the the tools of physics uh and a
lot of the concepts of physics
um at a kind of a lower level in the
sense of like you know
um obviously like uh
you know thank you physics for the
electron microscope thank you for uh
yeah yeah exactly crystallography oh my
goodness uh and you know and now we have
you know fancy fancier things like
cryo-em and and so on and that's all
great but you know like it's you know
for a day-to-day you know biologist I
might be like okay great so now I can
look really look at the ribosome and how
it makes proteins and that's all I care
about that's all I want to do I love
looking at ribosomes and that's all I
care about
but you know the fact is that a lot of
these physicists were actually like
saying no no no no no wait I
I don't care about the
the many many details of life and there
are many details of life I'm
just I want to know this big question
the question the shorter manager asks
what is life like I want to ask as a
physicist and
um and you know it's really neat to hang
out with the physicists today who are
still asking that question and still
working on these theories and and doing
some experiments to try to get at that
and um you know I I maybe
you know maybe these physicists will
actually like you know build a theory of
life
um and then we will you know maybe
someday we will look at life as just a
property of matter
um in the same way we think of
superconductivity as a property of
matter you know like not everything has
superconductivity
um but there's not just one thing that
has superconductivity like there's just
like these you can cut you can have a
theory to to understand how under some
circumstances some materials will have
superconductivity maybe we can say the
same things about life someday we can't
do it now we don't have a theory of life
right and maybe like superconductivity
it'll emerge as a consequence of a more
uh more com uh deeper complexity that's
hard to understand by merely breaking it
into the sum of its of its parts uh I
wonder as we're coming up on the hour
and I have several questions from the
audience and also
um uh my my existential questions that I
love to ask my guests if you're willing
to answer one or two of those
um when we uh when we think about the
discovery of extraterrestrial life
moving from the generation of life on
Earth perhaps but could extraterrestrial
life what do you think it would mean to
discover there's some other form of life
perhaps there's life here as past guest
Paul Davies uh you know might
hypothesize that there might be a shadow
biosphere hiding in plain sight or
lurking on some minor body in our solar
system what what would you think would
be the impact of a discovery let's just
not let's not say you know uh Ellie
arroway discovering you know you know 5D
tesseracts and whatnot but let's
restrict it to their slime mold
um Planet you know orbiting around
Proxima Centauri B and that's all there
is and but what what do you think that
would mean for our understanding not
only of life but of ourselves
well I mean scientifically I think it
would be a huge deal because
um you know you
you
either it will be a lot like
Life as we know it or it will completely
expand our concept of what it means to
be alive
um you know all of life on Earth is kind
of boring in the sense that it's all
you know DNA as far as speaking for
yourself you've never babysat my kids
Carlos well there might be interesting
extensions yeah no
boring just you know none
not in the phenotype but when you get
down to the genotype you know when you
get down to those molecules that are
carrying on life through the generations
it's all DNA and it's like I mean the
code is always is pretty much the same
it's just it's
um so it would be amazing as Paul Davies
had suggested like maybe there's RNA
life that's lurking you know in the tiny
pores of rocks where DNA life can't go
and eat it you know maybe a film base or
something a fifth base yeah yeah right
but um uh you know but you know I think
what's interesting is that uh is it's
been interesting to to look at the work
at how astronomers have been looking
um at and discovering exoplanets
um and you know I think we kind of
looked at our own solar system and said
like oh yeah I guess we get planets so
it'll be just like this well
no it's like it turns out like planets
around other stars or
kind of mind-blowing they just they
don't play by quite play by the rules we
thought the planets played by you know
so you just have you know these these
huge planets right next to their sun or
you'd have just you know planets going
around dead stars or just on all sorts
of stuff and so
um
it would be exciting if life you know
elsewhere in the universe challenged us
that that way even if it doesn't just
finding it would be amazing
but you know I I think that you know to
to a culture that has you know that has
uh
where you know we just we watch science
fiction movies and the aliens are all
you know bearing a very striking
resemblance to Hollywood extras it's
like I I think our foreheads yeah yeah I
just think people might you know feel uh
I I
I hope people will be able to to to feel
some of the excitement that scientists
will feel even if it's just slime molds
or bacteria
[Music]
I still think that that will be things
like that single-celled life will be
amazing if it's out there maybe it's not
right yeah that I mean my basic
prediction is that we won't find
intelligent life because simply the
argument always goes as made by Carl
Sagan and andrean and that apocal book
contact where they say you know if
there's not life out there it's an awful
waste of space but you know Carl I've
been to Antarctica twice uh to the South
Pole even and you know Antarctica has
won seventh of the Earth's space in
terms of Continental uh a shelf and uh
there's not much life there there are a
couple Penguins near the ocean some
seals uh there aren't even very many
microbes and certainly not a lot of uh
of Flora and so just saying that there
is you know a surface area on other
planets perhaps uh which is undoubtedly
true has no bearing on whether or not
it's probabilistic and in fact I'll run
this argument by you tell me what you
make of it it's not something I'm really
an expert in but the fact that we
haven't really discovered well we
certainly haven't discovered life in our
solar system outside of Earth uh We've
set in the thin kind of veneer that that
covers the Earth's surface or
tardigrades that float around I guess
but that's about it
um and yet the Earth has been exchanging
material just like the Allen Hills
meteorite Came From Mars
um and this meteorite came from the
asteroid belt so two are pieces of the
earth potentially carrying base pairs
and DNA enzymes and maybe even microbes
and tardigrades uh landing on presumably
on landing on Mars Enceladus in other
places so the fact that we don't see you
know any evidence for it of course you
can't say lack of evidence is evidence
of absence as Carl Sagan also said but
um I wonder it has to tell you something
about the prior probability distribution
the fact that you know if you did see
some form of life you'd say okay it is
once life gets started anywhere in the
solar system it immediately spreads that
can't be true because we don't see it
anywhere else but Earth so anyway you
can react to that if you choose but I
have a series of audience questions that
I love to also ask you
well you know we we haven't looked uh
all that hard for Life put it that way I
mean you know we may have we could have
potentially contaminated Mars already
with our spacecraft and but we don't
know yet because it's not as if there's
a microbiologist up there who is doing
the kind of research to find those
things there could be Subterranean life
in Mars and we have you know our probes
have not yet really like done the done
the work to to find it they found some
odd plumes of methane that might or
might not be life we don't know but you
know like there's
you know as you say like I mean
on Earth you know we we have Antarctica
we have the oceans which you know we we
barely explored
um and um you know you're not going to
you know if you've never seen a blue
whale and you go you know go take a swim
and you don't see a blue whale that
doesn't mean the blue whales aren't out
there right or a giant kelp ball like
you encounter here in La Jolla Shores At
the very outset of the book okay some
questions if you would uh give me your
forbearance to uh to ask of you so I
asked our friend Allison motri who uh
reminder we did a podcast with him in
studio here at UCSD a couple of months
ago and that title of that episode is uh
to help his autistic son he grows brains
in space a little bit of hype on my part
but but it is true he has a a very
personal mission as you know to conquer
autism and to explore the deeper regions
of the human brain and Allison says oh
yes I would love to hear from him if his
concept of life has changed after he
wrote the book and what he would call
life now even outside of Earth enjoy the
conversation he is very nice to talk to
[Laughter]
um
yeah
I I I I I was kind of you know life
concept agnostic before I think I'm more
so now I think that um I think I I the
philosopher Carol Cleland I think really
makes it very
um compelling case I feel it more
compelling now that
um it's just the wrong way it's just the
wrong way of going about understanding
life that that scientists should be
trying to to find a theory that explains
what we call life
um it's fine if we sort of have sort of
placeholders for uh for what life is but
I I you know
life transcends all that
um I I feel that more so than ever
having worked on this book
um good
and next turning to a question
tangentially related to uh future guest
on the podcast hopefully uh Professor
Rome Amari here at UCSD and that's your
work on covid
um this is sort of a kind of update uh
from the audience members and then I
have a follow-up sort of what is your
what is the best current thinking about
the origin of covet is uh you've written
definitively about it in the New York
Times and elsewhere what do you think is
the origin of we started off with like
religion so now we got to Pivot to
something very Contra we won't get into
anti-vaccination though don't worry uh
but tell me what is the best thinking or
perhaps your best understanding of how
covid in fact originated
well you know I mean the the
uh there has been
um you know there's been a group of
virologists who have studied you know
the emergence of viruses for a while and
they have published a couple papers in
science where they make the case that
um that there was a spillover multiple
spillovers at a market in Wuhan uh and
you know they uh you know they are they
Marshall evidence just in terms of like
distribution of of samples in this it's
Marketplace and an analysis of the
mutations and the virus
um
you know but uh you know if people want
you know to to have like a you know
video footage of a raccoon dog that's
like coughing and then that person next
to that raccoon dog
inhaled it and that person tested
positive and then you can trace from
there they don't have it uh we will we
would never be able to get that um the
animals
um that were that were there uh were all
killed
um so you know like we're we're in a
tough situation now there have been you
know certainly in you know Congressional
hearings talking about
um uh you know raising questions about
what was happening miles away at the uh
Institute of Urology other people have
pointed out this Chinese Center for
Disease Control had a had a facility it
was closer to the market
um you know like uh
if somebody were to say like you know
okay we have here we have this you know
this this lab data that shows that
you know here's this virus that was
collected from I don't know you know
let's say uh Southern China and it's the
sequence of almost SARS cov2 and then we
did this to it and that was the SARS
Kobe 2 genome then you know then you
could say aha but you'd still have to
explain why it is that a lot of the
early cases appear to have been
um not just people associated with the
market but just people who lived near
the market
um those those things have been
challenged by people who say oh well you
can't trust those early cases
well you know uh that's that's what we
we've got so far so you know I I'm sure
this is not a satisfying answer for
anybody it shouldn't be
um and uh you know I it would uh we
could certainly stand with
looking at more information
um and um you know uh
I I do think that you know it's it's
also important to uh to recognize uh
that
um
spillovers are a regular part of of uh
the world of pathogens
and um you know we've seen it with HIV
and SARS and influenza and so on and so
um you know regardless of the specifics
of what happened here we we know there
are lots of coronaviruses and bats we
know they get into other hosts we know
there's influence that we know they're
NEPA by blah blah blah there are a lot
of viruses that are knocking at the door
and so you know we need to and also the
the gain of function
type you know I've had covet only once
thankfully somehow my wife's been
managed to avoid it despite the numerous
children running around and all of us
having gotten it
um but you know I got it Carl and and I
I you know I dropped five pounds and I
always joke I dropped five pounds from
my chin to my stomach but no I I lost
weight you know I lost my sense of taste
and smell and it was clear to me there
were some you know benefits I mean I
hate to sound callous at all but I could
Envision after that and especially
um maybe you'll be sorry I'm saying this
but after reading your book I almost
thought well what if like some alien
civilization is using us for gain a
function for them uh I mean it's pretty
far-fetched especially for someone that
doesn't believe there's you know
Advanced extraterrestrial intelligence
that's regularly visiting us here in
Southern California but um but I wonder
Carl you know is it is it not true that
gain of function has potential utility
and to say that you know know we weren't
pursuing that in some level I mean
wouldn't that be kind of negligent on
behalf of behalf of people that support
scientific research and so forth that
maybe there are not not a covet
especially I killed a million people
plus worldwide but this concept of gain
of function do you see it as having
value
um well you know the term game well I
mean a gain of function is it's not
quite as as uh slippery a term as life
but it is pretty slippery like when
people talk about gain of function in a
sort of casual way I think like okay
well what are you talking about are you
talking about
um
I I think people are
like there's tons of signs that goes on
that might be described as gain of
function where you know cells are being
manipulated so they start doing
something they couldn't do before you
know yeah you know like like you know
like let's
uh you know our insulin where does our
insulin come from our insulin largely
comes from bacteria that uh were
engineered with human gene human insulin
genes
that's where we get our insulin from
that's gain a function if what you're
saying is like you know manipulating the
genes of an organism so they can do
something they couldn't do before
bacteria we're not making human insulin
before now they make it in huge
quantities
now people say people wouldn't say like
oh human insulin's a bad thing they just
think it's too expensive that's the real
controversy about it
um the reason that we're not concerned
about that is because we don't think
that these bacteria are going to kill us
all
however in the 1970s
I write about this in my book microcosm
some people did think that those insulin
bacteria were going to kill us all when
they were first invented they either get
out of the fermentation tanks and and
they would put us all in a diabetic
Comas like this was real
arguments people were having
that didn't happen
so
um you know so so again we have to
really be careful about what we are
talking about when we talk about gain of
function and so what a lot of the debate
has focused on uh in among scientists
and in government circles is
specifically about
doing experiments on pathogens or
potential pathogens
and or I should say pathogens that have
the potential to become pandemic
which sounds more precise but what do we
mean by potential like what is it like
how do you know in advance if something
is going to become a pandemic or not
and so you know I I think that uh you
know when peop when people are outraged
that anyone is doing any gain of
function
um I think they you know I think they're
not I think they need to look more
closely at all of the complexity of all
this and I you know there are trade-offs
here and there are there are fundamental
trade-offs here that I think are we're
just going to have to you know make a
call on in in a you know in a democratic
process and a real like deliberation
because on the one hand you know we are
very concerned about you know the the
I'm certainly concerned and I think a
lot of people are concerned about these
uh strains of bird flu right now that
are getting into a lot of people and a
lot of mammals
and um you know a few more mutations and
the one of these things could really
take off and and
you know could be worse than than covid
um
uh you know and and yet you know we
really like our our best understanding
of uh about the mutations that we should
be concerned about actually we know
about them
because somebody did real gain of
function research on bird flu viruses
back in like 2012 2013. the whole their
research freaked everyone out so much
that we sort of had the whole that's
when the whole gain of function debate
actually started because people because
there were people
um you know scientists who were saying
what are you doing you you are trying
you know they were basically trying to
make these bird Foods so they could be
transmissible between ferrets and other
people were scientists were saying like
whoa we should not be making these
things like you know it's like evolution
is already like you know doing this why
are we risking this you know this this
ferret adapted flu could get out and and
make people sick
[Music]
but you know the fact remains that that
research went forward and it told us a
lot
it we know what a lot of what we know
about in terms of the risks we are now
facing with bird flu we got from gain of
function research but it was terribly
controversial and a lot of a lot of
scientists in the field of thought
shouldn't have never been done
that's that's the that is the the real
trade-off that we face it's not a simple
uh choice to be made if we don't do gain
function research we're not we're going
to be things we don't know about
right in principle we could head off or
develop vaccines in advance and there's
a lot of uh Curative properties that
could be invoked and but like everything
it should a lot of people have said well
look it should never be done it should
be done but it shouldn't be done and
things can lead to human pathogenic
pathogenic response so uh Carl what are
you working on now you've done a lot in
the genetic space can we entice you to
write about what is a planet next or
what can we do to get you to move into
the Astro uh astronomical realm
um you know I I had I did I had a little
taste of that
um as I was sort of coming out of my
sort of 120 covid coverage all the time
it was really nice to sort of in the
past year or so to kind of start to
Branch out again into areas that are
handwritten about before and you know
now that the J the James Webb Space
Telescope is up and I I is open
it's fascinating and you know I'm
understandably drawn to their work on
planets and on possibly finding
habitable planets and um I've written
one piece on that and I'm I'm you know
keeping an eye on on on that research
because I just think that's just it's
incredible to be alive when we have
tools that can let us see those things
for the first time yeah
so Carl I always end uh my conversations
with a quote from Arthur C Clarke one of
his many quotes uh he's very quotable uh
one quote I love to quote to my
department chair frequently is for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert that usually shuts them up pretty
quickly uh but I'm gonna ask you a
different one to comment on the
following statement made famous by Sir
Arthur C Clarke that any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic and I'll ask you uh if you
look at the whole of human history what
is the most magical technology that
human beings have ever been able to
create
foreign
[Music]
interesting uh
I have to say that the first thing that
comes to mind is the technology that
is making a pause for me to look at you
in California right now and have a
conversation with you
um I just this you know this this is
kind of bizarre like we I think a lot a
lot of people got got accustomed to what
the internet could provide in terms of
connection during the pandemic with zoom
and that was a drag and I mean and
anybody who's tried to teach by Zoom as
as we have knows that what a nightmare
can be but
still
this is kind of amazing to me and um uh
yeah I mean I think things that you know
make communication possible uh maybe
because I'm a writer uh maybe that's
what I'm prone to but uh I'd have to
vote for that communication technology
very good uh so Carl Zimmer uh author of
many many renowned author many many
wonderful books from life's Edge we
spoke about today too she has her
mother's laugh we'll talk about that I
think that came out the same month that
my first book came out in April of 2018
so it's the fifth anniversary happy
anniversary Carlton a wonderful book
which is lauded around the world and
this book of course received rave
reviews uh the New York Times called it
you know shimmering and zipping with uh
with his uh phenomenal pros and I uh I
just want to thank you for sharing your
time with us today and I hope to see you
back in the future and I hope you have a
magical rest of your day from here at
the Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination at the University of
California San Diego Brian Keating your
formerly fearful host signing off thank
you Carl
thank you it's been a pleasure
foreign